[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans Ça vous
regarde c'est dans une heure et demie
maintenant le débat d'entre deux tours
des deux finalistes de l'élection
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron Marine Le
Pen match retour 5 ans après vous allez
pouvoir suivre ce débat sur LCP à 21h ta
pente avant cela dans cette émission
vous allez tout savoir grâce à nos
invités des enjeux pour les candidats de
leur stratégie mais aussi des coulisses
de ce débat qui a fait l'objet d'intense
négociation l'image sera évidemment au
cœur de ce débat et ça tombe bien parce
que notre grand témoin ce soir est un
homme d'images il a joué un rôle clé
dans le débat Mitterrand Giscard en 1981
il nous dira quels sont les recettes
pour réussir ce grand rendez-vous
télévisuel le réalisateur Serge Moatti
est avec nous ce soir enfin dans le scan
ce soir élisez-moi Premier ministre
l'appel de Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour les
législatives ce sera dans l'oeil de
Blacko le couple franco-allemand va-t-il
divorcer après la présidentielle on
verra cela avec Richard Verly et puis
les derniers clips de campagne sous la
loupe de voilà pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs c'est un Grand Rite
électoral très attendu des Français
l'acné d'une présidentielle tous les 5
ans le débat d'entre eux de Tours Macron
Le Pen Le Pen Macron s'est à suivre à
21h sur notre antenne bonsoir Serge boat
bonsoir je suis ravi de vous avoir mon
plateau il y a de l'excitation dans
l'air quand même juste avant toujours
un grand ouais c'est comme toujours ça
sert à rien
j'ai pris un taxi j'ai failli mourir
d'angoisse en taxi je vous jure le type
ça sert à rien c'est toujours le même
truc nous pour nous ça bouge pas il y a
beaucoup de je trouve de fantasmes de
France pauvre con française
de 40 ans le 5 mai 1980 à 25 millions de
spectateurs étaient devant leur
télévision pour suivre le débat Giscard
Mitterrand c'était déjà à l'époque un
match retour il faut le rappeler on en
parlera et vous étiez conseillé
audiovisuel de François Mitterrand on va
y revenir évidemment bonsoir Franck
Tapiro ravi de vous accueillir le regard
du communicant sur ce plateau on vous
doit notamment le slogan de Nicolas
Sarkozy ensemble tout devient possible
c'était 2007 et bonsoir Céline braque
bonsoir le regard de la sondeuse
indispensable directrice générale
d'odoxa notre partenaire pendant cette
présidentielle vous nous direz qui est
le plus à gagner ce soir qui a le plus à
perdre au regard des derniers rapports
de force on va commencer quand même par
les règles du jeu de ce débat c'est vous
Serge moiti qui avait contribué à les
écrire noir sur blanc en 1981 elles ont
été approuvants négociées
quand même avec les équipes de Giscard
et à l'époque le CSA n'existait pas
comme nous le rappelle Clément Méric
si on vous invite Serge Moatti c'est que
les débats d'entre-deux tours sont un
peu votre spécialité c'est vrai les
Français vous connaissent d'abord en
tant que réalisateur documentariste
passionnés de politique mais vous avez
aussi été le conseiller audiovisuel de
deux candidats socialistes à la
présidentielle c'est vous qui murmuriez
à l'oreille de François Mitterrand en 81
et 88 et de Lionel Jospin en 1995 un
candidat pas forcément très bon élève
d'ailleurs il y a pas eu du tout si vous
voulez dire de médiatraining ou de
préparation télévision WhatsApp pas du
tout Lionel Jospin n'est pas du tout
quelqu'un comme ça donc il a travaillé
le fond et pas la forme j'en ai
l'impression
bon Lionel Jospin pas fan de médias
training mais vous non plus d'ailleurs
votre vrai spécialité c'est plutôt le
pouvoir de l'image c'est vous qui avez
codifié la façon de filmer les débats en
fixant 21 règles en 1981 plan de coupe
distance entre les fauteuils et surtout
cadrage des candidats autant de détails
qui n'en sont pas à vos yeux si par
exemple lui il fait un très gros plan de
moi allez-y faites après vos plans vas-y
fais un gros plan
c'est pas la même perception que si il
s'éloigne au niveau rapidement bon très
bien on fait un autre essai si s'il se
met par terre vas-y baisse c'est pas la
même impression c'est pas la même
impression évidemment que s'il se met en
plongée et moi je baisse d'accord ça
c'est ça s'appelle le langage du visuel
on a une génération vos enfants les
miens qui sont nés avec la télévision
pour une fois on prend son langage là au
sérieux une fois tous les 7 ans ça va
non ce soir les deux finalistes vont
jouer le match retour d'un débat qui
avait tourné au fiasco pour Marine Le
Pen en 2017 oui chercher dans vos
dossiers vous seriez bien
que vous allez être en difficulté
j'ai pris la décision de permettre à
générer de rentrer dans la salle mais
moi personnellement
qui fait des téléphones et l'autre ça
n'a rien à voir effet à la fois des
turbines et du matériel industriel c'est
pas la même chose alors Serge Moatti
selon vous Marine Le Pen a-t-elle appris
de ses erreurs et Emmanuel Macron de
quoi doit-il se méfier enfin vous
l'homme d'images passionné de politique
à votre avis la présidentielle peut-elle
se jouer ce soir
pas mal de questions
on commence on va commencer avec ce
qu'on appelle le pouvoir des images le
langage audiovisuel c'est vous qui
l'avez un peu inventé dans ce genre de
débats
ont été établies avec Robert Badinter en
1980 valeur de plan distance entre les
candidats place un peu en retrait des
journalistes racontez-nous ça ce qui se
passait en régie il faut pas que ce soit
une fois tous les 7 ans à l'époque une
fois tous les cinq ans maintenant faut
pas que ce soit un truc comme ça peu
importe de façon dont on fait ça bon non
non il y a des règles il y a des règles
parce que c'est un langage au sens
propre on parle avec la caméra moi j'ai
passé mon temps ou dans des films de
fiction ou dans des documentaires avec
des acteurs ou avec des gens de la
vérité enfin de la réalité
à trouver un langage à chercher un
langage par exemple je vais pas
recommencer ce que j'ai fait tout à
l'heure là vous m'avez coincé avec ces
vieilles archives que j'avais totalement
que j'avais totalement oublié mais par
exemple si par exemple parlez-moi alors
Serge Moïse qu'est-ce qui se passait au
régime
plein de coupes d'accord si je fais ça
ça vous fournit c'est hyper intéressant
le contre-chant c'est fondamental
finalement dans un domaine
et strictement interdit en 1980 les
plans de coupe vous les aviez interdit
vous les aviez interdits
21 règles avant de faire le débat de 80
ans vous rendez compte 21 règles et dans
la presse de droite de l'époque on
disait voilà la télévision nord-coréenne
que les sociétés se promènent tu parles
de télévision
[Musique]
ça veut dire que c'est vous qui disiez
en régie allez gros plan on disait ça au
réalisateur et vous pouviez avoir ça
parce que je suis pas sûr que ça
possible ce soir neutre
et il y avait deux types derrière lui le
conseiller de Giscard et moi conseiller
de Mitterrand et Olivier les deux pour
moi la une pour moi le numéro de caméra
vous voyez là c'est la 5 par exemple qui
me filme c'est la 5 en la 5 vient fait
faire gros plan la 5
bon il fait pas mais
le groupe
quand on parle d'un gros plan d'un plan
large ça a l'air idiot mais c'est pas la
même chose si je vous dis avec émotion
mes parents sont morts que j'avais 11
ans je m'en suis ça a été terrible pour
moi en gros plan il y a plus d'émotions
peut-être qui passe que si il est très
large très large non mais attendez
les candidats peuvent choisir leur
valeur de plan l'un et l'autre différent
il y a encore des conseillers il y a une
charte il y a une charte de réalisation
qui est très stricte mais c'est vrai que
vous aviez un pouvoir qu'ils n'ont pas
même si on va voir qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de choses hein
on va en parler je voulais vous montrer
la photo de vous avec François
Mitterrand ce jour-là c'est juste avant
le débat vous êtes à coudé on voit les
cataly qu'est-ce que vous lui dites là
exactement vous rappelez
il est là il faut bien le regarder comme
ça
je sais plus il y avait une
histoire de dossier aussi
dommage que vous n'ayez pas la photo du
dossier parce que j'avais inventé un
truc dont je suis pas fier mais vous
m'obligez à ne pas être fier et à me
mettre dans une
désarroi total humiliation complète
c'était l'époque des diamants de Bokassa
vous savez
et j'avais mis un dossier devant lui à
Mitterrand mais alors
je fais le geste comme ça
a
si vous énerve trop à un moment du débat
monsieur
je vous ai mis un dossier là il me dit
mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce dossier
simplement si vous énerve trop vous
faites ça
la petite menace
et j'avais dit après à mon homologue le
dire un truc mais tu me jures que tu en
parles pas
[Rires]
ok j'ai besoin d'un gros plan à un
moment parce qu'il va sortir des trucs
il en parle pas mais 2 minutes après
tous les lisez de courant et donc c'est
des je suis pas fier de moi vraiment je
suis pas fiable mais
c'est un jeu c'est un langage ça marche
pas et si l'autre tu avais dit mais si
l'autre jusqu'à que j'aimais bien par
ailleurs si l'autre qui avait dit sortez
ce que vous avez là sortez ce que vous
avez là
c'est passionnant de vous entendre parce
que il y a encore beaucoup d'invariants
il y a pas mal de choses qui qui demeure
de ces années-là de 190
que lui que j'aime vraiment bien par
ailleurs mais s'il est loin de moi on
parle pas pareil parce qu'on porte la
voix que si ce qui me dérange dans le
débat de ce soir
alors il y a une chose qui va qui va
changer par rapport à 2017 c'est à dire
que les fameux plantes couples les
plantes d'écoutent comme on les appelle
ça on ne pourra en avoir tout à l'heure
que si c'est des plans de regard c'est à
dire que Marine Le Pen qui trifouille
dans ses notes ça c'est terminé n'en
veut plus elle c'est un recul ça ou pas
votre avis total pourquoi parce que vous
l'avez très bien dit pour moi depuis
toujours ce qui se passe aujourd'hui de
débat c'est le point d'orgue émotionnel
une campagne présidentielle et donc
comme c'est le point d'organisationnel
on a beau dire il y a plein de légendes
oui ça change rien ça change tout moi ce
que je sais c'est que tout le monde
attend ça avec impatience c'est une
finale la Coupe du Monde et c'était un
moment de sport c'est très proche de la
Box vous savez avec la pesée où il y a
de l'intox on se regarde on envoie des
petites phrases dans les journaux on
fait croire qu'on est blessé parfois
pour mettre l'eau en confiance et en
fait on arrive en forme on fait croire
qu'on des dossiers sur les diamants en
fait c'est faux il y a du bluff c'est un
match c'est un match passionnant et plus
on est dans la sincérité plus on délivre
cette émotion et en plus les gens le
grand public maintenant connaît
tellement l'audiovisuel bien mieux que
nous parce que c'est eux qui ont
vraiment les non non pas uniquement les
spectateurs mais les acteurs maintenant
si on leur enlève une part d'émotion si
on leur a vu une part de sincérité on
leur enlève le débat donc moi je trouve
que politiquement c'est une erreur 1 de
les mettre à 2 mètres 50 parce que pour
moi c'est loin c'est trop loin il faut
qu'on s'approche nous la relation le
pouvoir se toucher pratiquement à peine
de mettre à peine de mettre mais c'est
très loin le fait que on puisse pas voir
les réactions même des réactions mais
c'est pas humain et en fait si on les
déshumanise alors qu'aujourd'hui on sait
qu'il y a une défiance totale de la
classe politique on est à côté de la
plaque pour moi voilà pour que j'attends
ça avec impatience en même temps
j'espère que je serai pas déçu les
Français avant de regarder justement le
studio qu'on va découvrir évidemment en
direct tout à l'heure à 21h mais on a
quelques images on va vous les montrer
c'est une bracelet Français attendent ce
rendez-vous les sont toujours suivis
même si la plupart des gens vont dire oh
là là c'est quand même un peu ennuyeux
c'est sans doute très très long parce
que c'est prévu pour être durer au moins
2h40
et il y a quand même en suspense
vraiment dans ce débat là puisque le
précédent vous l'avez rappelé a été un
fiasco pour Marine Le Pen qu'on voit
quand on regarde aujourd'hui dedans par
exemple dans le baromètre politique
qu'on a fait ensemble quand on regarde
les côtes d'adhésion des deux on voit
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont à égalité c'est
à dire 38% d'adhésion pour Marine Le Pen
38% d'adhésion pour Emmanuel Macron et
pratiquement autant en rejet
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on a 45% des
Français qui disent je ne veux pas
entendre parler de Marine Le Pen et 41%,
il y a quand même une différence qui est
pas très forte entre les deux donc il y
a un vrai si vous voulez un vrai
suspense il y a égalité sur d'autres
éléments on reviendra peut-être parce
que chacun a ses atouts et c'est c'est
au contraire c'est faiblesses sur pas
mal de sujets donc qui est un suspense
et les gens vont voir cette fois-ci si
Marine Le Pen arrive à gagner ses galons
de candidate crédible c'est vraiment
l'enjeu on va parler évidemment des
enjeux pour les deux candidats sur le
fond comme sous la sur la forme comment
se sont-ils préparés ces dernières 48
heures et puis à quoi ressemble ce très
grand plateau de la Plaine Saint-Denis
vous allez le découvrir avec Nicolas
Coadou tout de suite
voici la reine dans laquelle les
finalistes à la magistrature suprême
vont s'affronter ce soir un studio de
150 mètres carrés en plein cœur de
Saint-Denis deux heures trente
d'opposition animée par les journalistes
Gilles Bouleau et Léa Salamé
on est là pour s'assurer que la stricte
égalité est respect
ée s'il
y en a un tunnel de 4 minutes on sera là
pour couper donner la parole à l'autre à
quelques heures de l'échéance les
équipes des candidats se relaient sur le
plateau tout doit être millimétré de la
température de la pièce 19 degrés au
nombre de caméras 16 les candidats
seront te séparés par deux mètres 50
après tirage au sort Marine Le Pen
ouvrira le bal avec une minute trente
d'introduction le premier thème abordé
sera le pouvoir d'achat suivront les
retraites la jeunesse l'environnement
l'immigration et enfin l'international
une réalisation tout aussi codifiée
cette année interdiction de filmer les
candidats regardant leur fiche seuls les
regards fixes seront diffusés à
l'antenne vu qu'on est coincé dans des
plans figés qu'on peut pas faire des
zoom avant des zoom arrière des grands
mouvements de grue des travellings etc
ça va être le rythme de mélange des
caméras et la vitesse de ces changements
de plan correspond à
au fait qu'il faut pas que justement
qu'on s'ennuie pour éviter le fiasco de
2017 il se que Marine Le Pen se prépare
chez elle depuis 48 heures en vérité
c'est un bon naïf de penser qu'on se
prépare quelques heures avant en vérité
on s'y prépare depuis peut-être pas six
mois depuis 5 ans mais c'est peut-être
l'exercice de toute une vie merci
Emmanuel Macron lui depuis l'Élysée
travaillerait avec ses conseillers sur
ce qui serait son point faible son
arrogance comme le rapporte Le Canard
Enchaîné je n'ai pas besoin de coach
comportemental cherchez plutôt des
arguments percutants aurait déclaré le
candidat il y a 5 ans 16,5 millions de
personnes avaient suivi le débat
d'entre-deux tours c'est absolument le
contraire
ça vous plaît ce plateau ce plateau bleu
vous qui avez l'habitude c'est très
codifié encore
moi ce qui me plaît pas c'est les deux
mètres 50 désolé je n'y arrive pas de
mettre ils vont ils vont faire comme ça
haut-parleur
qui décident des modalités de
réalisation
d'un marchandage entre les chaînes et
les candidats mais
pour garder le lead ça s'appelle garder
le lead et c'est vrai que le chef de
l'État sortant et chef de l'État ce soir
il apparaît non pas que le disait Chirac
ce serait il y a un premier ministre
après absolument c'est le premier
ministre limitant il l'a tué quand même
un chef de l'État sortant et une
candidate donc il doit quand même garder
lead donc évidemment les deux quand
c'est le mettre la pression pour garder
l'île vous allez voir il va se passer
aussi autre chose extraordinaire qu'on
connaît c'est avec les deux animateurs
pour qu'il garde le leader il va falloir
qu'ils prennent beaucoup d'élan parce
qu'avec les deux talents qu'ils ont ce
soir et en fait c'est quoi c'est quand
on arrive à s'affranchir des questions
et bien sûr et ce qu'on ou reformule les
questions
on choisit franchement on a l'impression
que même le casting a été décidé par les
candidats mais ça c'est pas très
démocratiquement parce que on avait fait
quand même deux débats avant avec si
vous parlez de Mitterrand mais là je
vous parle d'aujourd'hui alors là qu'on
choisisse Michel cotta et encore une
fois en 1980 je veux bien mais en 2022
Anne-Sophie Lapix non
c'est tout simplement parce que
rappelons-nous ce qu'a dit Madame Le Pen
à peu près 8 ans devant
les caméras de télévision chez Guillaume
Durand où elle a dit que Anne-Sophie
Lapix et sa clique donc ça donne le
président de publicité serait suspecté
de vivre dans un monde assez fermé avec
des gens qui vivent ensemble qui mange
ensemble qui vont en vacances ensemble
qui mettent leurs enfants les mêmes
écoles bien entendu c'est vieille tel
antisémites qui traînent depuis des
années des années Guillaume Durand était
tellement estomaqué qu'il n'a même pas
pu répondre donc Anne-Sophie l'a dit que
c'est un peu brocardé par le Front
national le rassemblement national et
Marine Le Pen et malheureusement ça
fonctionne depuis que ce soit elle a été
écartée du débat aux États-Unis
et ravi de vous accueillir vous êtes
politologue aussi qui a le plus à perdre
ce soir dans ce débat au vu des des
rapports de force
les les deux ou les deux ont à gagner
les deux ont à perdre sachant que ça va
pas beaucoup changer de toute façon
je la donne ou pas ça c'est la première
chose on va en parler j'imagine une
longuement il faut bien faire la
différence entre la façon dont on
reconstruit à posteriori les médias les
débats une fois qu'on sait qui a gagné
c'est très facile ensuite de puiser une
petite phrase en disant ça a été la
phrase choc celle qui a fait gagner tel
ou telle candidat on l'a dit pour VGE on
l'a dit pour Mitterrand on peut dire que
certaines petites phrases font gagner
mais ça c'est après coup à l'avant si on
le sait pas toujours
que pour Macron qui a une avance s'il
fait match nul ce soir il garde son
avantage
moi je dirais du coup que c'est Marine
Le Pen qui a le plus à perdre et à
gagner c'est à dire que pour elle
aujourd'hui quand on regarde leur
compétences en comparatif on va voir
d'un côté
la qualité qui sont attribuées à Marine
Le Pen qui vont être qu'elle est elle se
sent elle sera plus proche des gens elle
serait plus sympathie mais mais elle
serait moins
femme d'État moins capable finalement de
de pouvoir être à la moins démocrate
aussi moins compétente et ça pendant un
débat elle peut marquer des points parce
que sur ces sujets là pas très
compétentes pas pas assez fan d'Etat
elle a déjà gagné du terrain donc elle
peut encore marquer des points dans un
dans un débat comme celui-là et Emmanuel
Macron Soro la lui va être qu'elle n'en
gagne pas tout en disant on l'a dit
juste avant il faut pas qu'il paraissent
arrogant parce que le petit extrait
qu'on a montré précédemment tout le
monde a trouvé ça excellent à trouver
excellent aujourd'hui il fait la même
chose c'est à dire qu'il dit mais Madame
Le Pen c'est
la nature
je pense qu'il doit être capable de
pouvoir la contredire sans tout en
faisant attention de ne pas paraître
arrogant donc c'est c'est plus difficile
lui comme il a une marge d'avance y
compris en intention de vote il a
intérêt à la garder et lui n'arrivera
pas en revanche à en un débat paraître
plus sympathique et plus proche des gens
c'est
Marine Le Pen elle a peut-être fait elle
a gagné des points comme vous l'avez dit
mais tout seul là il va falloir marquer
les points face à l'adversaire justement
c'est une revanche n'oublions pas que
c'est une revanche ou elle est sortie
massacrée c'était même pas à Ko c'est
même pas Chao technique en box je pense
que ça serait directement en réanimation
n'oublions pas aussi il faut être très
très vigilant de ça parce que on a eu un
précédent c'était Giscard contre
Mitterrand on sait très bien comment
s'est passé le premier puisque Giscard
n'a vraiment porté avec tout monopole
mais le match retour Mitterrand a
remporté de façon magistrale
et ce soir je pense que c'est très
important pour Marine Le Pen je crois
qu'elle a au contraire elle a tout a
gagné elle elle doit façon elle était
tellement massacrée il y a 5 ans que
elle peut pas faire pire
elle peut surprendre si elle se trompe
encore si elle maîtrise pas ses dossiers
sur les sujets oui mais le président
sa nouvelle incarnation je suis la mère
de famille des Français
vous êtes tous mes bébés je suis là pour
vous protéger je
vous salue mes petits chats n'ayez pas
peur j'aime les chats je vous aime vous
les Français bon donc c'est très bien
c'est quand même une nouvelle image de
Marine Le Pen c'est le grand
remplacement elle a réussi le
remplacement elle a remplacé l'image de
2017 par une Marine Le Pen alors on dit
que c'est Marine Le Pen mais elle est
tellement rempl
acée
tu sais tu dois pas parler comme ça
c'est sûr emmerder les Français
le cortège de petite phrase mais ce
serait efficace vous pensez
je veux
gentil je vous aime tous que vous soyez
à gauche à droite c'est pas le sujet
musulman
ou non oui
je sais je sais je sais je sais et elle
doit beaucoup Azemmour mais
elle va être formidablement gentille
ce soir il a un bilan il va être forcé
sur son bilan le président doit présider
même un débat et le président doit
garder le lead c'est lui qui garde le
tempo c'est lui qui garde les horloges
et lui qui garde les thèmes et s'il perd
le lead s'il est en défense il perdra le
débat et de mémoire dans un cinquième
République on peut dire que ça marche ou
pas je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un gagner
un débat perd une élections
et le gagnant du débat et tout le temps
le favori alors c'est comme ça je n'ai
jamais vu l'inverse moi j'ai des petites
difficultés dans dans ce débat
parce que tout simplement encore une
fois je disais on fait de la
reconstitution a posteriori
et on confond aussi les perceptions
qu'on peut avoir les jugements et ce
sont souvent des professionnels de la
communication des journalistes dont des
personnes tout à fait qualifiées pour le
faire mais ça c'est le jugement qu'on
peut porter pour le débat et puis
ensuite l'impact réel sur les intentions
de vote et ensuite sur les votes par
exemple je vais vous donner un exemple
sur la page
pour terminer cette différence entre les
perceptions par exemple on est tout le
monde est d'accord y compris Marine Le
Pen sur le fait qu'elle l'avait loupé le
débat de 2017
l'impact a été très marginal
je vous propose on a un sujet sur la
question de l'influence de ce débat
d'entre-deux tours sur le résultat final
on a un sujet et je vous donnerai la
parole parce que au fond les études des
politologues de Sciences Po aussi vont
nous éclairer évidemment on va revoir
les phrases cultes vous en avez cité
déjà pas mal pour le plaisir de revoir
ces archives parce que ça peut être
aussi ce qu'on va chercher le moment qui
fait tout basculer la petite phrase
préparée la tirade l'énervement de
l'adversaire pour le plaisir de ceux qui
aiment la politique regardez c'était
signer les
monopole du cœur vous n'avez pas il est
en train de dire que la droite elle-même
peut avoir une dimension affective
Giscard d'essa avait compris à ce moment
là que pour désamorcer quelque chose de
François Mitterrand il fallait lui dire
vous en parlant de soi vous avez
tendance un peu à reprendre le refrain
d'il y a 7 ans l'homme du passé c'est
quand même ennuyeux que dans
l'intervalles vous soyez devenu vous
l'homme du passif là je crois que
Mitterrand apporte un élément de
modernité dans la langue politique en
étant simplement presque dans le dans le
slogan publicitaire c'est comme de
l'escrime et à ce moment là Mitterrand
porte sa botte
ce soir
je ne suis pas le premier ministre et
vous n'êtes pas le président de la
République nous sommes deux candidats à
égalité tout à fait raison monsieur le
Premier ministre sur le plan
psychologique François Mitterrand
réussit quelque chose alors qui est qui
est assez terrible pour l'adversaire
parce que là on peut dire qu'il y a une
sorte de mépris de fait il dit à l'autre
finalement vos arguments sont peut-être
bons mais je les annule complètement je
suis très en colère et les parents et
les familles qui vous ont et les parents
non je ne me calmerai pas du tout
je voudrais vous dire pas je ne me
calmerai pas parce que non il a fait
tomber vraiment c'est Golan royal dans
un dans un dans un piège et le piège
classique de des humeurs féminines alors
je crois que Ségolène Royal n'avait pas
tort de d'être dans l'émotion mais elle
était peut-être trop en avance et
aujourd'hui tout le monde est en colère
la colère est un argument politique mais
à ce n'était pas encore le cas
moi président de la République je ne
serai pas le chef de la majorité je ne
recevrai pas les parlementaires de la
majorité à l'Élysée moi président de la
République je ne traiterai pas mon
premier ministre de collaborateurs moi
président de la République c'est un faux
moi parce que lorsqu'il dit moi
président évidemment il dit vous voilà
comment il fait le portrait en creux de
Nicolas Sarkozy et donc il l'accuse d'un
certain nombre de mots et ça a été très
préparé il le fait c'est vraiment un
moment de bravoure comme on dit dans le
théâtre
je vous dis juste une chose regardez ils
sont là ils sont dans les campagnes dans
les villes je parlais de votre sur les
réseaux sociaux
parlent du parti de l'extrait les
envahisseurs c'est contenu beaucoup
pendant les deux heures elle a essayé
d'être extrêmement sérieux cette
technique et puis là tout d'un coup
quelque chose se passe je pense qu'on
est quand même dans son inconscient
comme si elle croyait pas tout à fait
elle-même au rôle qu'elle est en train
de jouer et elle a fiction dont elle est
l'héroïne
alors justement quel peut être la phrase
culte de ce débat on a voilà encore
plusieurs plusieurs dizaines de minutes
à 21h on le saura toutes ces phrases
choc Serge Moatti toutes ces formules
elles sont milites maîtres elles sont
travaillées il y a rien de spontané il y
a plein de choses spontanées parce que
moi je sais pas ce que vous allez dire
je sais pas ce qui est mais vous qui
avez travaillé avec François Mitterrand
vous voulez nous parler français
par exemple Monsieur le Premier Ministre
c'était hyper répéter on était tous dans
son bureau à l'Élysée là et on était
trois quatre quoi enfin bon et chaque
fois il devait jamais se gouré dire
monsieur le Premier ministre monsieur le
Premier ministre monsieur le Premier
ministre ce qui était flatteur pour moi
mais bon alors répéter comme ça donc ça
c'était répété
de c'est à dire que
c'est en l'occurrence
on était formidable celui qui s'énerve a
forcément tort celui qui s'emporte on
n'a pas on pense à la colère saine la
scène colère de Ségolène Royal
Sarkozy qui était réputé pour quelqu'un
un peu nerveux etc c'est au contraire
maîtriser et essayer même d'empêcher
Madame Royal parce que il n'a pas accusé
de scénario calmez-vous Madame Royale
calmez-vous c'est qu'il a même essayé de
l'empêcher de s'énerver donc il
apparaissait comme empathique il était
presque sorti du démon disons en off non
mais ces collègues
ce soir ça veut dire quoi être à
l'offensive prendre le leadership mais
ne jamais s'énerver mais oui est-ce que
on s'entraîne il y a du média training
pour ne jamais s'énerver c'est très
compliqué parce que c'est un tempérament
c'est très compliqué est-ce qu'on change
quelqu'un non non ne change pas
quelqu'un et quand vous changez
quelqu'un comment vous apparaissez comme
un sincère et là c'est la vérité je peux
vous dire les gens ont un détecteur de
sincérité ils le savent vous pouvez
avoir une sincérité du moment raconter
n'importe quoi pendant un moment pendant
2h40 je peux vous dire vous craquez à
maman donc il vaut mieux être soi-même
tout le temps parce qu'à un moment on
peut tout reprocher mais quand vous êtes
pas vous-même il y a pas pire vous êtes
condamné je suis absolument d'accord
avec mon stack de face essayer de faire
sortir de ses gonds qui ce soir les deux
c'est ça quand même tout le monde a
essayé c'est l'objectif
Marine Le Pen au-dessus de la meiller
mêlée elle va le titiller simplement je
peux rajouter un tout petit truc
c'est un problème d'incarnation tout le
temps mais vraiment et c'est très
compliqué l'incarnation moi je connais
bien ça avec les acteurs c'est pour ça
que bon un acteur par moment il joue
faux bon et parce que on lui a mal
dirigé
puis quand on change le rapport qu'on a
avec l'acteur quand on lui dit mais toi
par exemple tu vivrais cette situation
comment tu réagirais dis-moi comment tu
réagirais tu viens d'apprendre un truc
terrible ou un truc amoureux enfin peu
importe comment tu réagirais et donc on
le prend à part on évite le côté les
autres qui Rican ou je sais pas quoi on
le prend pas et vient un personnage
décent du cintre enfin des projecteurs
comme ça et moi j'ai appelé ça le dieu
c'est mon côté mysticot le dieu des
scènes
oui mais c'est la même chose avec un
homme politique il doit pas être
quelqu'un d'autre pendant un débat c'est
lui les images les plus
clair très clair je pense que les images
dans la vie politique même en dehors des
débats les plus marquants les plus
ridicules sont des politiques qui ont
été en dissonance cognitive Édouard
Balladur dans le métro Alain Juppé qui
joue au pire pong et c'est ces moments
où le communicant est mauvais sans doute
en disant tu as l'air commencer alors
soit moins coincé fait donc une bonne
partie de Beer Pong c'est vraiment c'est
il y a je voudrais qu'on dise un petit
mot aussi du fond des dossiers parce que
on sait que Marine Le Pen a beaucoup
travaillé beaucoup préparé ce débat ce
sont les dossiers qui lui ont fait
défaut on l'a vu avec cet échange sur
Alstom SFR avec Emmanuel Macron il y a 5
ans aujourd'hui il y a le pouvoir
d'achat pour commencer la parler
d'international donc forcément de
Poutine de ces liens avec Poutine de
l'Europe aussi qui va essayer de coincer
qui et sur quoi en fait c'est elle qui a
commencé à reprendre ce que les études
disaient il y a quelques mois parce que
tout le monde y a c'est elle qui a sorti
de pouvoir d'achat c'est faux toutes les
études donnaient le pouvoir d'achat
comme une des préoccupations des
Français elle était maligne compris de
son électorat exactement elle a repris
mais en revanche je vais vous donner
parce que c'est facile de dire le
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat c'est
comme Zemmour qui a parlé l'islamine de
sécurité et puis finalement il a fini
assez pour cent elle c'est bien de
sortir le pouvoir d'achat mais regardez
ça mesure phare c'est le panier
d'aménagère donc un panier avec son
produit à prix bloqué
avec 100% a pris bloqué c'est que les
fabricants sont morts les distributeurs
sont morts c'est pour tuer l'économie
c'est exactement ce qu'il faut faire
donc en fait ce soir c'est comme est-ce
qu'elle va se défaire de ces mauvaises
idées sur le pouvoir d'achat de son lien
quasi je dirais
filiale avec avec Vladimir Poutine qui a
quand même droit de vie ou de mort sur
son parti puisque il est question grâce
à une banque vous le savez très bien
tenue par des militaires etc donc elle
est complètement comme ça avec Poutine
comment est-ce qu'on peut élire un
président ou une présidente qui n'a pas
une indépendance surtout en ce moment
avec le contexte que nous vivons non là
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire il va
falloir qu'elle fasse de l'Aïkido
l'Aïkido c'est ne pas frapper c'est
prendre la force de l'adversaire c'est
de la retourner contre l'autre s'il y
avait pas de l'Aïkido elle va se prendre
malheureusement son propre programme sur
la tête c'est rivedel à lui donc le
risque d'arrogance à elle le risque
d'incompétence on a vu revirement
notamment sur le voile l'interdiction
dans la rue ces derniers jours et en
même temps il y a quelque chose quand
même qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
tout ça c'est une évolution de long
terme parce que vous parliez tout à
l'heure d'une image qui s'est
une image qui s'est adoucit pour la
campagne et tout ça mais il faut voir
que bien avant en fait Marine Le Pen
elle a repris le Front national puis
ensuite ce qui est devenu le
rassemblement national en 2011
et à partir de ce moment-là il y a déjà
eu une rupture rupture sur le plan
économique elle est passée du
libéralisme de son père à quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus interventionniste
une plus grande attention au service
public et finalement elle a touché de
plus en plus et c'est ça quand même
qu'il faut retenir et c'est l'électorat
qu'elle vise un électorale
ça doit nous interroger c'est-à-dire les
gens les plus démunis dans la société
ils se reconnaissent davantage dans le
peigne que dans Macron donc
et en partie autrefois il votait à
gauche ils auraient voté parti dans le
passé
on le voit ça dans les études
donc à 21h Emmanuel Macron arrive à
faire tomber les masques sur la question
européenne sur la question russe
notamment sur l'écologie aussi sur les
accords de Paris est-ce que ces
électeurs celles que ceux à qui elle
s'adresse ce soir ils seront sensibles
ou pas forcément non c'est à dire vous
votre public de fan n'est pas sensible à
la critique de l'adversaire et sera
toujours derrière vous ce qui est
intéressant ce sont les cibles
c'est-à-dire en l'occurrence pour Marine
Le Pen et pour les deux d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron en particulier des gens
qui ont voté Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou des
gens qui n'ont pas voté du tout et c'est
cela qu'il faut pouvoir convaincre
tantôt regarde parce que quand on
regarde leur compétences de l'ordre dans
les dans les différents domaines
d'action ce qu'on voit c'est que elle
est
privilégiés par les Français les
Français considèrent qu'elle est
meilleure sur les impôts sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur la sécurité l'immigration
elle est moins bonne que Macron sur la
place de la France à l'international
l'environnement l'éducation la santé le
chômage et donc si vous voulez que des
petits trucs mais bon elle a elle a le
pouvoir d'achat et il est dessus il va
falloir qu'elle soit très très solide
pour que des électeurs qui seraient
tentés par un vote Marine Le Pen ne se
disent pas ok d'accord en fait c'était
que du flan donc c'est à dire que si
Emmanuel Macron est bon dans l'exercice
il va pouvoir
essayer de démonter le panier de la
ménagère
un sujet et après il leur intérêt à
appuyer sur la place de la France à
l'international et le possible
renversement d'alliance ce sont des
sujets pour les électeurs hésitants et
vous savez que quand on regarde les
intentions de vote on a encore près de
10% des lecteurs qui disent qu'ils vont
voter mais qui savent pas qui hésitent
encore entre les deux cela ça vaut le
coup pendant ce débat d'ESS
la difficulté je suis assez d'accord
mais la difficulté pour Emmanuel Macron
c'est que s'il veut en effet démonter
les propositions de Marine Le Pen sur un
plan très technique il va apparaître
comme un technocratique or je sais mais
le débat c'est aussi une histoire de
symbole peu importe le panier la
ménagère avec prix bloqué on s'inquiète
pas des conséquences et ça sera pas la
première fois qu'un politicien ou une
politique fait nos promesses sans
s'interroger sur toute la mécanique
derrière et pour s'apercevoir qu'il kiné
c'est impossible à mettre en oeuvre mais
le symbole frappe et et peut-être
Emmanuel Macron il a pas intérêt à aller
sur le terrain de la trop grande
technicité parce qu'on dira bah voilà
lui c'est un technocrate oui surtout
qu'en plus il a le costume de président
ils discute avec Biden ils discute avec
avec Poutine il va falloir qui qu'il
enlève le costume pour être candidate
une candidat populaire face à un
candidat qui était le candidat du
quotidien des Français je pense que
c'est le vrai enjeu pour Emmanuel Macron
c'est de montrer parce que quand on est
au pouvoir
partout là on est quand même un peu loin
des réalités c'est toujours comme ça on
est toujours un peu isolé là ça le
démangeait d'être sur le terrain et on
le voit il a raison il a raison mais là
aujourd'hui
donc il n'est pas décroché le décrochage
existe chez tous les souverains ça
existe depuis des siècles et avec les
présidents de la République on sait très
bien que dès qu'il rentabiliser il y a
une forme qui risation mentale et de
distance par rapport aux Français
aujourd'hui
sont plus élevés du côté de Macron
justement il est pour vous ce sujet on
vous la promette qui sont déterminants
ces débats est-ce qu'ils ont un impact
sur le scrutin et surtout sur les
indécis on a commencé à en parler alors
ils sont toujours très suivis hein 16
millions de téléspectateurs il y a 5 ans
c'était 23 Serge moitié 23 millions en
1981 Marco 1er et Joseph mcdelaine ont
promené leur micro gare Montparnasse à
la rencontre des Français ce matin
oui je regardais le débat ce soir est-ce
que ça m'intéresse la politique que
chacun des deux envisage envie de voir
comment les deux se débrouillent avec ça
oui c'est plutôt une curiosité je veux
dire une curiosité presque théâtrale des
Français curieux de ce match retour en
très manuel Macron et Marine Le Pen même
si beaucoup ont déjà fait leur choix
pour le second tour comme Anissa elle a
voté Macron il y a 10 jours ce soir elle
soutiendra son champion je voudrais voir
Macron très fort ce soir pour justement
faire changer d'avis à certaines
personnes et pour montrer que
Marine Le Pen n'est pas sa place quoi
d'autres sont encore indécis barrage aux
extrêmes votes blancs abstention c'est
le dilemme de Charles ou de marque pour
eux le débat de ce soir pourrait être
décisif qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
ce débat
bah que les choses soient bien claires
des deux côtés sur les promesses qui
font et puis voir à peu près comment que
ces volumes au niveau de leurs promesses
fonctions de ce qu'ils vont se dire
entre eux j'espère vraiment que les
candidats vont pouvoir amener quelque
chose de mieux qu'un clash qu'on a
l'habitude de voir regarde je perds pas
avoir du puéril et plus du constructif
un débat constructif de fond c'est ce
que souhaite la plupart des Français
rencontrer aujourd'hui programme contre
programme surtout sur le pouvoir d'achat
la retraite mais pas que ce que
j'attends principalement c'est
le débat sur l'Europe j'aimerais bien
qu'il y ait un peu plus de social dans
tout ça qui est un peu plus d'humain un
peu moins de problèmes financiers comme
un peu tout le monde on attend pas mal
un débat axé sur l'écologie les
questions de demain vraiment j'ai un
enfant je voilà je j'ai envie de savoir
quelle va être mon avenir et le sien
alors finalement que nous apprend la
science politique sur l'influence de ces
débats est-ce que je peux te dire un mot
mais très rapide quand même sur la
méthodologie et tout ça je vous
embêterai pas mes raisons même un petit
mot de cuisine déjà pour être très
rigoureux il faut interroger les gens 3
fois normalement une fois avant le débat
une fois immédiatement après le débat et
une fois après le jour de l'élection
parce que il va y avoir des petits
changements probablement ce soir
d'intention de vote mais ne se réalisera
pas forcément le jour de l'élection les
gens vont peut-être réfléchir revenir à
autre chose quoi vous voyez donc il y a
le voilà déjà écouté très sérieux trois
fois un échantillon assez considérable
parce que comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure 16 millions de personnes
regardent ce qui est énorme en termes
d'audience télé c'était beaucoup plus
auparavant mais ça fait quand même que
le tiers de l'électorat le tiers de
l'électorat voilà 16 millions 16
millions ça fait le tiers de
l'électoratrice
ou convaincu déjà convaincu d'aller
voter pour leurs champions ou au
contraire ça peut faire basculer les
indécis d'abord la fonction première
c'est de confirmer les gens dans leurs
intentions de vote et chacun va
interpréter regardez même être attentif
au débat en fonction de ses préférences
préalables on va retenir la petite
phrase ou la petite escarmouche qui nous
touche ou voilà on va dire ouais très
bien et au contraire on va on va mettre
de côté ce qui est ce qui nous déplaît
donc déjà pour l'essentiel des
téléspectateurs c'est ça va être une
confirmation alors il peut y avoir des
petits mouvements en 2017 on avait vu
quelque chose de d'un petit peu plus
important que d'habitude c'est-à-dire
deux types de mouvement des gens qui
voulaient s'abstenir auparavant et qui
finalement se sont décidés à voter pour
Emmanuel Macron peut-être en se disant
bon Marine Le Pen elle ou elle est elle
est très inquiétante et d'autre part des
gens qui voulaient voter initialement
pour Marine Le Pen qui se sont réfugiés
dans l'abstention il y a très peu de
évidemment de passage de l'un vers
l'autre alors là on a quand même quelque
chose intéressant c'est le fait qu'il y
a les lectorat de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
est assez considérable donc après a
priori bon les instructions les c'est de
les directives des dirigeants c'est de
ne pas voter pour
Marine Le Pen mais quand même on sait on
va passer vous l'avez pas voté Macron
non et en plus on sait que dans son
électorat il y aura peut-être ça dépend
des tempêtes
une très belle proposition prenez-moi
comme premier
avec Stéphane blackovski qui nous attend
Céline braque d'accord avec ça les les
finalement ceux qui regardent sont
pratiquement tous déjà convaincus ça
peut pas forcément être si déterminant
et c'est à dire que c'est clairement ça
c'est à dire qu'on voit même que de
enfin deux personnes peuvent avoir une
vision complètement différente du débat
c'est c'est assez étonnant je suis tout
à fait d'accord sur le fait que en 2017
c'est un des rares débats où on a pu
dire que il y avait eu une influence sur
le vote alors pas non plus qu'il a
changé le cours du vote parce que
Emmanuel il y avait une tendance qui
était déjà à l'oeuvre
il y a beaucoup beaucoup on l'a vu même
avant le premier tour d'indécis cette
année ah oui je pense que s'il y a
vraiment un public sur lequel le le
débat peut agir c'est les indécis il y a
plein de gens qui se disent je dois
aller voter je vais aller voter mais je
ne sais pas encore pour qui et ils ont
aussi les entre Mélenchon un peu Macron
un peu ils sont vraiment perdus parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens perdus il
faut le dire quand on a décidé parfois
perdu il y a pas parce que les acteurs
Unis c'est un choix vous décidez de vous
abstenir mais comme vous ne savez pas
c'est pire voilà pourquoi je pense que
va être beaucoup plus surprenant une
très grosse demi-heure maintenant
exactement
le dernier petit tour de table avant
d'accueillir nos scanners vous le sentez
comment imaginez d'un mot vous pensez
que ça va se passer ça sera vraiment de
la saillie face à face
je prépare endormi du tout je serai
ardent non non j'y crois au débat je
crois la force de la démocratie
pour le débriefing et donc j'aimerais
pas m'endormir entre deux 23h 30 minutes
j'arrive d'elle non non la politique est
un continuelle renouvellement Franck
Pierrot pour conclure c'est le retour
c'est Rocky 2 € qui 2 c'est encore plus
fort que rien est-ce qu'il y a une
victoire
dans les matchs pour prévenir Raymond
Domenech d'ailleurs ce matin l'ancien
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France dans
le but merci absolument
pour vos éclairages vos analyses le
débat vous avez compris il est pour le
moins important si ce n'est déterminant
merci à vous vous restez avec moi Serge
moitié on va parler à présent de celui
qui va le regarder c'est sur ce débat
c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon on le disait
elisez-moi Premier ministre il a il a
lancé ça aux Français dans une formule
dont il a le secret on en parle tout de
suite dans le scan
[Musique]
mais avant les drones il y a les deux
fatalité au grand remplacement et bien
moi je vous propose le rouge d'allemand
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la République c'est moi la France orange
macronique
travailleuse travailleur le système vos
exclu il y a un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la France sa grandeur
c'est le vol
sur ce plateau nous ont rejoint pour
continuer à scanner des crypter passer
au crible cette entre-deux-tours avant
ce débat important Richard werli bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être là le quotidien Le
Temps bien sûr et chroniqueur dans cette
émission Brandon bonsoir
journaliste politique avec une vraie un
vrai tropisme pour pour l'histoire et
puis l'oeil de Blacko qui évidemment
c'est braqué sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce
soir
un peu comme tout le monde ici j'imagine
alors quelle surprise on s'attendait pas
du tout enfin presque pas du tout mais
c'est vrai quand même le soir du 1er
tour quand il a dit que
faites mieux on sentait qu'il voulait
passer le relais aux jeunes on avait
l'impression de regarder Midi Libre a
compris la même chose que moi maintenant
il est temps de se passer devant une
nouvelle génération et d'ailleurs le
lundi qui a suivi premier tour sur
France Inter c'est la jeune génération
qui a pris le relais Adrien catenens
on comprend que l'avenir de ce pays à
gauche ça n'est pas la social-démocratie
c'est ce bloc populaire que nous avons
constitué je vais vous dire une chose
quand on voit la configuration d'hier il
s'agira aux élections législatives de
faire le nécessaire parce qu'Emmanuel
Macron je le crois peut ne pas avoir de
majorité à l'Assemblée il peut s'agir de
lui imposer une cohabitation vous voyez
il est clair il est structuré il
s'exprime bien c'est vraiment un jeune
qui a de l'avenir comme ça qui côté
comme qui n'ont voté que Mélenchon
et je vais vous dire pourquoi
laissez-moi vous dire pourquoi Monsieur
allez-y mets tout simplement parce que
personne n'imagine 4 nains sa Matignon
alors que quand c'est Jean-Luc qui dit
la même chose et qui parle de
cohabitation hahaha est-ce que c'est le
charisme qui fait la différence on
regarde non seulement vous devez sécher
vos larmes mais la loi de la vie c'est
que c'est la vie qui est la plus forte
et dans la vie c'est le combat qui est
le plus fort si bien que je suis venu ce
soir vous dire une chose je demande aux
Français de mes lire Premier ministre
je leur demande pour mes lire Premier
ministre délire une majorité de députés
insoumis
insoumis et union populaire c'est un peu
de mal à venir populaire il avait un
dans cette union populaire alors il faut
traduire union populaire c'est une idée
du service marketing des insoumis pour
parler de l'union de la gauche mais
l'union de la gauche c'est un produit
qui ne se vend plus donc comme ça arrive
on le rebattise pour lui donner une
deuxième chance ça marche regarde ou pas
RPR rebaptisé en UMP rebaptiser une
républicain oui ça a des limites quand
même le changement de nom pour relancer
un mouvement restons sur l'Union
Populaire je vous résume 32% pour la
gauche là-dedans Mélenchon pèse à lui
seul 22% vous connaissez cette phrase de
Diard j'imagine quand les types de 130
kilos disent certaines choses les gars
de 60 kg les écoutent oui évidemment
hein quand les Verts font 5% ils ne
pèsent pas lourd donc c'est fini le
temps où Jadot disait oui j'aurais se
retourne dans sa tombe quand il écoute
Mélenchon ouh là là là
ne nous fâchons pas il est pas loin de
s'excuser Julien Bayou maintenant
à la limite il faudrait des excuses de
part et d'autre c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
deux choses il y a d'une part des
désaccords et d'autre part la
compétition électorale qui a exacerbé
nous on a aussi notre lot de mots
urticants qu'on a reçu je pense qu'il y
a eu des échanges d'amabilité entre
guillemets qui qui font pas honneur à la
politique c'est certain je pense qu'on
peut accéder des désaccords dans le
respect voilà ne nous fâchons pas tous
mais les socialistes alors dans tout ça
ils rejoignent populaire
on en est pas là
ils ont fait ils ont fait 2 % à la
présidentielle donc il cherche sauver
les meubles et quand je vous parle de
meubles je vous parle pas de ça je vous
parle pas desagères je vous parle de
siège de sièges à l'Assemblée nationale
qui ne sont pas très confortables mais
sur lesquels on peut rester assis 50 et
ça pour un socialiste avouer quand même
que c'est quand même un truc assez sympa
donc ils ont tendu la main les pauvres
socialiste à et les filles et regardez
le râteau que ses prix ce pauvre Olivier
fort mais qu'il n'est pas d'eau a dit
non pas question de s'unir sauf que
depuis Jean-Luc Mélenchon et il a dit le
contraire je crois mais ça c'est ce que
je vous disais les jeunes insoumis ils
sont encore un peu tendres Mathilde
panos et les laisser entraîner par la
soif de vengeance et le dieu est arrivé
en disant calmez-vous les gènes résultat
le bureau national du PS ils étaient
convoqués hier soir ils ont voté pour se
rallier à Mélenchon enfin pas tous 160
pour 75
le PS oui c'est vous êtes triste
c'est ma vie ça mon papa était résistant
déporté etc et Parti socialiste
clandestin à la Libération là où
j'habite et puis tout ça
ma vie entière si j'ose dire c'est bon
pour le boulot alors écoutez c'est pas
foutu c'est pas foutu Serge redresse les
vous d'abord tenez-vous droit comme ça
regardez l'avenir parce que la
social-démocratie son dernier mot c'est
ce que justement vous connaissez Carole
Delga est-ce que on dit les socialistes
sont foutus pas du tout mais non les
régions 60 villes voilà regardez on
avait prévu la carte on devance aux
paroles 5 régions sur 13 60 villes la
sociale démocratie encore un mois à dire
et elle a l'accent du Sud-Ouest la
société démocratique on l'écoute bien
sûr que non il n'y aura pas de
rassemblement derrière la France
insoumise il y a déjà de ça 5 ans
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'a pas eu la dignité
d'appeler à voter pour la République et
pour Emmanuel Macron et là ça recommence
ma position elle était toujours très
claire je n'ai jamais aucune faiblesse
vis-à-vis de communautarisme je n'ai
jamais aucune faiblesse vis-à-vis de la
violence je ne peux pas cautionner la
violence dans une société et l'Europe je
pense que c'est notre destin commun je
vous souhaite la parole Serge je voulais
dire que c'est pas gagné qu'on
mélangeant voilà c'est pas quoi gagner
pour Mélenchon
c'était juste il y a peut-être encore
une
[Musique]
je comprends pas
c'était une chronique sur au fond cette
main tendue à tout voilà les électeurs
de gauche pour faire de l'huile le futur
premier ministre pour les législatives
la cohabitation
on va en reparler mais on enchaîne un
peu de valium
allez on avance on va parler avec vous
ce soir de ces clips de campagne parce
qu'il y a toujours des clips de campagne
et même des nouveaux clips jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'à au deuxième tour un rituel
de campagne en tout cas qui n'intéresse
pas Emmanuel Macron à tel point qu'il a
même pas pris le temps d'en faire la
promotion sur ses réseaux sociaux nous
tous c'est le nom de son nouveau clip de
campagne en réalité on aurait pu aussi
le renommer femme je vous aime
mes filles vont avoir 7 ans et 9 ans
cette année je m'appelle Sarah et il y a
deux ans je suis partie en Erasmus à
Madrid
je m'appelle Luna j'ai 25 ans et je suis
infirmière je veux que les vide de lona
Sarah lova et de tous les Français
puissent continuer de s'améliorer dans
les cinq ans à venir Emmanuel Macron qui
s'efface on le voit très peu à l'image
pour donner la parole aux Français non
plutôt aux françaises il avait déjà joué
la tour féminin dans son premier clip de
campagne et voilà reparti pour un tour
sans doute parce qu'on lui reproche un
entourage trop masculin et vous avez
remarqué tout au long de son clip
Emmanuel Macron présente uniquement en
voix off avec un champ lexical là aussi
romanié il ne s'agit plus de se
focaliser sur son bilan mais accès
davantage son discours sur le projet
qu'il souhaite mener avec beaucoup de
pronoms jeux et nous c'est un moyen
aussi de rassembler et pour évoquer son
bilan bah il prend appui sur son adverse
sur son adversaire si comme le
préconisait la candidate d'extrême
droite nous n'avions pas fait confiance
à l'Europe à la science et au vaccin
nous ne parlerions pas de ces vies
changer mais de confinement de chômage
de déclin de la France
Emmanuel Macron il fait comme Marine Le
Pen sur sa nouvelle affiche de campagne
il a passer son nom dans son discours et
avec cette voix off très très posée
c'est comme s'il sortait d'un état
léthargique on effaçant le nom de Marine
Le Pen il a en même temps effacé sa
ténacité ça c'est vérité en rupture
forcément avec les nombreuses images on
le voit avec des bains de foule qui
tentent forcément de cacher cette
nonchalance du discours le contact la
proximité c'est aussi c'est aussi le
pari et la stratégie images de Marine Le
Pen c'est une vidéo étonnante que la
candidate du rassemblement national a
partagé sur ses réseaux sociaux hier on
n'est pas dans son clip de campagne là
on est dans une autre vidéo c'est un
format assez rare pour Marine Le Pen
dans une vidéo de 7 minutes où elle
change aussi ses habitudes à quatre
jours du second tour elle a enfin décidé
de tout miser sur son programme rien que
son programme écoutez-la le projet
d'Emmanuel Macron pour les 5 prochaines
années vous le connaissez c'est un
projet de violence sociale il sera à
l'image de son premier quinquennat tout
en brutalité tout en arrogant et tout en
impuissance j'aurais dû dire rien sur
son programme voilà il y a un air de
déjà-vu non présence dans ce clip non
c'est un clip qui prend une nouvelle
fois la forme d'un plaidoyer contre
Emmanuel Macron on voit une Marine Le
Pen qui ne sourit jamais elle affiche un
ton très grave très sévère un regard
aussi très déterminé oui c'est la maman
mais là elle est plus sympathique comme
dans son premier clip de campagne on la
voit avec ses sourcils français la
gestuelle saccadés toujours avec cette
sempiternelle musique de fond un très
mielleuse qui vient justement cacher et
montrer une dramatisation différente et
quand on a terminé d'attaquer son
adversaire que reste-t-il plus beaucoup
de temps mais un peu quand même pour
conseiller ces électeurs dans leur choix
dimanche c'est pour la restauration des
évidences républicaines que vous voterez
vous voterez pour que vous voterez pour
que soit protégé vous voterez pour
défendre l'unité vous voterez pour
préserver la solidarité vous voudrez
pour la primauté effectivement
j'ai moi-même que coupé comme ça parce
que au monde justement que Marine Le Pen
n'aime pas les invectives elle préfère
les injonctions à Marine Le Pen a troqué
ça sa robe d'avocate pour pour le
costume de juge reste à savoir si elle
ou Emmanuel Macron ce sera dimanche soir
le rôle et le costume de chef d'État
merci beaucoup
les clips de campagne ça compte ça
compte pas
dû couper comme ça
secrétiens c'est pas ce qu'elle a voulu
faire passer elle à vous votre réel elle
insiste quand même à 12 reprises dans
son clip c'est une forme de souligner
les choses mais vous l'avez dit
l'important c'est de
la veille d'une élection pardon
Marine Le Pen je défends le langage
audiovisuel c'est pardon
vous faites ce que vous voulez
on sait pas quoi Serge mot atti est
invité justement pour défendre ce que
c'est que non mais là
allez on y va sur sur Richard qui va
nous qui va nous parler d'un tout autre
sujet mais vous allez voir c'est lié à
l'élection présidentielle le couple
allemand c'est vrai qu'il a été très
attaqué par Marine Le Pen dans cette
campagne mais vous nous dites ce soir
Richard que il y aurait du plomb dans
l'aile aussi en cas de victoire de
Macron pour pour ce coup pour ce tandem
oui alors on va se projeter dans l'après
alors ça y est le nouveau président de
la République est élu et vous savez qui
évidemment il y aura l'Allemagne en face
en général le premier voyage il est à
Berlin Marine Le Pen elle a dit non elle
a dit que son premier voyage sera à
Bruxelles et vous avez remarqué qu'elle
a eu sur l'Allemagne un ton extrêmement
agressif alors quelques faits quand même
parce qu'il faut bien les rappeler pas
car ce sera la réalité de lundi
l'Allemagne a bien des égards c'est
quand même l'opposé de la France c'est
une démocratie parlementaire plutôt
apaisée ou couverts actuellement une
coalition entre sociaux-démocrate
écologiste et libéraux c'est un
excellent commercial de 173 milliards
d'euros alors que la France a un déficit
de 84 milliards c'est un taux de chômage
inférieur à 5% alors que la France se
réjouit
donc voilà l'Allemagne depuis longtemps
absolument donc l'Allemagne en plus
dirigé entre 2005 et 2011 par une et
2021 pardon par une figure à savoir
Angela Merkel mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que Marine Le Pen
Emmanuel Macron ont une lecture
totalement aux antipodes de cette
réalité allemande pour Marine Le Pen et
si elle est élue elle devra le mettre en
œuvre l'Allemagne utilise sa puissance
pour museler pour imposer sa loi à la
France il faut donc si opposer il faudra
trouver des alliés à la Cité monsieur
Orban notamment elle redoute le
réarmement de l'Allemagne sur fond de
guerre en Ukraine pour elle c'est un
partenariat absolument toxique pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est le contraire il
voit dans le couple franco-allemand
l'instrument d'une puissance commune
c'est son idée d'une souveraineté
européenne pour lui besoin Berlin a
besoin de Paris et vice-versa le
président français il n'aime pas
tellement l'atlantisme des Allemands qui
ont toujours les yeux tournés vers les
États-Unis mais il voit l'Allemagne
comme une garantie parce que Madame
Macron il fait des calculs économiques
et il sait bien que la solidité de
l'euro elle dépend largement de la
première puissance économique européenne
et pourtant l'avenir n'est pas forcément
entre Paris et Berlin et voilà et c'est
là que Marine Le Pen d'une certaine
manière elle devance peut-être un peu
l'échéance alors elle elle veut la
provoquer elle veut affronter
l'Allemagne mais la réalité c'est que le
couple franco-allemand après cette
élection il va quand même tanguer il va
tanguer d'abord parce qu'il y a un défi
autour de l'énergie et du gaz russe on
le sait les Allemands ne veulent pas
couper le robinet il y a un défi autour
de nucléaire les deux les deux candidats
français veulent du tout nucléaire et il
y a d'autres choses notamment le fait
que Olaf scholls le chancelier allemand
il n'a pas l'assurance d'Angela Merkel
il est beaucoup plus hésitant il regarde
beaucoup plus vers Washington donc de
toute manière l'Allemagne elle sera au
centre des préoccupations françaises et
dès mardi 25 avril dès lundi 25 avril
pardon le casse-tête Paris Berlin sera
de toute façon à l'agenda de l'Elysée
merci beaucoup vous entendez la petite
musique de fin merci il y a un débat qui
nous attend très important merci
beaucoup Richard merci infiniment Serge
moitié d'être venu ce soir allez place à
cette grande soirée politique sur les
chaînes parlementaires LCP Public Sénat
Brigitte boucher Thomas Hugues qui
prennent la main avec leurs invités
avant ce débat d'entre deux tours 21h
très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]